this is all being pushed on us
by wild ideologues who who want us to
see our countries in this remorselessly
negative light who want to turn all of
the things that were good in our
societies to bad who want to take all of
our heroes and just throw them down
sometimes quite literally and smash them
on the floor
to say look there's nothing good about
you
what have you got to celebrate
[Music]
hello and welcome to trigonometry i'm
francis foster i'm constantine kitchen
and this is a show for you if you want
honest conversations with fascinating
people we're delighted to say that our
brilliant and returning guest is
journalist and author and the author of
the upcoming book the war on the west
douglas murray welcome back to
trigonometry for the nth time
hey great to be back with you both it's
a real pleasure it's been too long
it has been too long and we of course
look forward to having you back in the
studio where we've had many of our
previous conversations uh but you have a
new book which is about to come out
which is called the war on the west uh
you got there ahead of me by a couple of
months because i have a book coming out
called an immigrant's love letter to the
west so i'm trying to talk about what i
think is valuable and what we don't
appreciate enough uh in the uk and
america and elsewhere in the
anglo-sphere
who who is fighting a war in the west
why is the west under attack douglas in
your opinion
well my viewers it probably ties in with
what i i think you're describing in your
book i mean there's a there's a wild
underestimating of our own societies in
countries like britain united states and
so on we
there's been this ravenous
self-criticism
that's sort of ended up being a form of
self-hatred there are lots of forms of
anti-westernism in the world you know
there's a
russian anti-westernism chinese
anti-westernism
middle eastern anti-westernism all types
but the one i'm really interested in is
is the western anti-westernism
the people who
who just say these terrible and
uncrucially untrue things about our
societies
uh and have been doing so for a very
long time and have just been getting
away with it i think they've just had a
for
various reasons they've had a
free run at us uh almost uncontested
so that uh people in the west say things
about the west which are
just not true
at the very least
very much not fair
and i i think they've just left this
field wide open i think a lot of people
in the west have been cowed by this uh
have been just so scared of the things
they've been called of the names they've
been called of the implications
uh of pushing back in any way
but i think it's high time that people
pushed back i i think we've got
our own estimation of ourselves wildly
out of sorts
and
sometimes it needs somebody i mean
constantly as i understand you're doing
you know somebody who has come from
outside a
democracy like britain to say actually
hang on a moment guys most of the world
isn't like this you know
whilst you're talking about uh
the rights of ivf for lesbian couples or
whatever you know
uh much the rest of the world's they're
hacking their neighbors to death i mean
i mean don't
don't get your estimation of yourselves
to
so wrong and sometimes it needs an
outsider as well to say that somebody
who's come into a country and
it says look you've just you've got
yourselves really out of proportion i
think there's no country in the world
that's more the case with an america
where for all sorts of reasons um
america going to in the book american
citizens just just have a
misunderstanding not just about their
own country and its history
but a misunderstanding about what the
world is like
what the rest of the world is like now
and what most of the world has been like
historically
douglas
when i was a kid i we're from the
same generation when we looked at
america it was always a stereotype that
americans were fiercely nationalistic
uh
overly proud that the criticism would be
of their own country why has it suddenly
shifted so dramatically in recent years
with this attitude
yeah that's right
i think all of us who who weren't born
in america sort of had
this view of america as being as you say
fiercely nationalistic patriotic you
know swearing allegiance the flag lots
of things that say british patriots
patriotism didn't want to do
you know flying the flag in your front
yard as they find a person in britain
who'd you know do that without cringing
well you know there was a we sort of
prided ourselves in britain on having a
quiet form of patriotism and thought of
americans as having a noisy form
in our own lifetimes this is completely
flipped
uh
there are of course many patriotic
people in america who still have the
same estimation of their society that
they once had but a vast swathe of the
country uh
now has a totally different
understanding the story of america used
to be a story of heroism of
individualism of us of freeing from
tyranny uh a much more a book i've got
behind me paul johnson's history of the
american people published only just over
20 years ago opens with a sentence that
says something like america is the
greatest
invention of human species to date you
know i mean you could say that sort of
thing even as a non-american
not much more than 20 years ago today
you'd be derided if you said anything
like that
because the whole history has been
reframed
essentially it's been reframed for the
same reason the rest of the history of
the west has been reframed through the
prism of original sin in the case of
america through the prism of slavery
where everything is seen remorselessly
through the prism of slavery we have the
1619 project of the new york times not a
fringe project uh that set out
when it was founded a couple years ago
now set out and stated that its aim was
to reframe the founding date of america
to move it to 1619
in order to commemorate the date when
slaves were first brought in
uh to the american continent now i mean
this is a this is a deliberate attempt
of course to say
our nation started in slavery we can't
get away from it uh with a follow-on
suggestion we sort of never should we
we're stuck with it we're stuck with our
legacy well who isn't stuck with our
legacy first of all what the hell are
people meant to do about that now um but
but everyone's got a version of this
obviously in britain we have empire and
and you could say as a fair estimation
is is to say
well slavery and an empire were sort of
the sins of these things were slightly
glossed over
in the past maybe massively glossed over
at one point a few generations ago
and that we're going through a period of
churn because we're looking at the
downsides where people used to talk
about upsides and so on
and and and and it's possible but i
think if that is what's been going on
it's just gone on uncontested for far
too long
um so that so that people haven't just
corrected uh basic untruths
it's not the case that american school
children aren't taught about slavery
it's not the case that british school
children are not taught about uh the
colonial era or are taught that the
colonial era was some sort of grand
wonderful thing we should return to you
know it's just not the case and i've
gone through all the textbooks of the
schools in in both countries just just
to
shoot this down once and for all you
know american and very school children
are brought up with a um
a lot of a lot of teaching about the
original sins of their societies
we've got quite enough of that um but it
does it does reframe the country and i i
don't understand why we can't look at
all of this in the round
except for the fact that
with this is all being pushed on us
by wild ideologues
who who want us to see our countries in
this remorselessly negative light who
want to turn all of the things that were
good in our societies to bad who want to
take all of our heroes and just throw
them down sometimes quite literally and
smash them on the floor
to say look there's nothing good about
you
what have you got to celebrate
douglas and one of the things that i
find very disconcerting about the events
of the last few years in particular is
i don't really know what a healthy
patriotism looks like anymore when i
came to this country in the mid 90s i
remember people would in this country in
the uk would say something like well
this is the british way or this is
unbritish or an american particularly
people would say this this is america
and that meant certain things it meant
that people are free to have different
opinions or whatever and also if someone
said something is un-american we all
universally knew what that meant and yet
now we're stuck in a position when
francis brought up the idea of
patriotism itself he was even in the way
that he described it was inextricably
linked to nationalism and we've kind of
got to this point where i don't even if
someone asked me i would struggle to
define how we can be proud of ourselves
in our country and our history and our
heritage without then becoming these
evil gammon
you know bigots with maga hats
and whatever is the caricature that we
are being presented with and i know that
you think about these things carefully
as do we we don't want to go off one
deep end in in order to oppose another
one we want to find a healthy course in
the middle what does that look like
um i think it's having pride in the
things that you've done well um having
pride in
in the things that are remarkable about
your country
um
my late friend roger scrutin used to say
that the
nation state was the widest possible
application of the first person plural
that is that you could say we about
them so we say when we did this
that it was i mean of course there are
versions of that with i know football
teams for instance people say we won
last week i wonder how would you do you
stood on the terrace and you
drank beer and you shouted at a guy a
lot better than you to run you know
that's not exactly we but
but
of course people do do that with with
with football teams with uh with sports
they think of they think of a collective
even if they themselves have had
almost nothing or nothing to do with the
success of that collective now that
nevertheless they're part of it
now that that that should be the case
with the nation state when we did that i
remember some years ago in a
conversation with trevor phillips
uh being very struck and very moved when
he said at one point in our conversation
when we did this and referring to
something that in elizabethan england
and i remember thinking that's great
you know like that's great
uh for um a black uh
british child of immigrants
to britain to say we about the
elizabethan era was just like that that
that to me seemed like almost the ideal
um that you were so integrated that you
would that you would you would feel like
that you say say that now
of course it's easier to teach the
opposite in a way
and it's it's it's fairly easy to teach
people a jingoistic nationalistic
simplistic view of their own past
um
and that has been done at times in the
past i think
in most countries
uh the late peter houston off used to
joke about being when he was a school
boy being you know having a poster in
his classroom i think of of of jesus you
know sort of signaling to a map where
you know
most of the world was was was colored
with the color of the british empire you
know he thought as a schoolboy you know
maybe jesus wasn't necessarily
entirely you know involved in the
creation of the british empire but but
he'd look into it you know the point is
maybe there was a
time when that was the case but um
you're right that the
patriotism and nationalism particularly
in britain we worry about we worry about
one going into the other i don't have
any particular problem with nationalism
per se i wouldn't call myself a
nationalist i don't think of myself as a
nationalist i'm i'm slightly nervous
about the term and i've said this quite
often
um
but
but but the reason why we don't like
nationalism let's be frank about it and
i said this in berlin a couple of years
ago to significantly
not much applause
but
just like one of our gigs douglas
i said
wait was it a
it's not that we don't trust
i don't know
countries in the far east to be able to
be nationalists or in the middle east or
i mean there's sort of forms of
nationalism in south america or
or africa it's not it's not that we
don't trust that i mean like
nationalistic movements are kind of
accepted around the world it's that we
don't trust europeans with nationalism
let's go a layer forward it's that we
don't trust germans with nationalism
for very good reason so
my my belief is is basically the
the justifiable fear of german
nationalism spilled out into a european
fear of nationalism in general
in europe and then into a fear of
nationalism across the west which has
now
come to america as well
and um
i think that is a shame because
patriotism is inside of nationalism
um
but
how you feel it i don't know i mean i i
i don't like to over analyze these
things because they're they're both
obvious and hard to describe it's one of
those things you know you know it when
you see it i mean i'm i'm not
nationalistic but i'm i'm i think myself
doing pretty patriotic because um
i
i said this in a book some years ago
that
uh was edited by
gordon brown and therefore read by
nobody
but
but i said there my attitude towards
them
um my own country has always been one of
gratitude i i i feel um i feel very
grateful uh for it um partly because i
know what the options the alternatives
might have been and i i i find myself i
know i'm not a great flag wave or
anything but i'm i'm i move i very moved
by my my nation by what it's done well
and and so i and i don't like hearing it
talk down i don't like people talking
about
uh heroes of the past in this incredibly
negative light i mind it i i don't i
really resent
ideological uh
extremists for instance trying to attack
winston churchill on the most specious
spurious grounds
um i i i mind because i know that what
they're doing is they're attacking
one of the holy places of britishness
and they're saying
they're saying it's nothing you guys
even
even winston churchill wasn't anybody in
america there's a version of this they
attacked thomas jefferson they attacked
abraham lincoln you know and it's like
if you haven't got lincoln then you've
not really got america
you you you see what i mean
and and the patriot recognizes that and
and dislikes it um and says no that's
not fair that's just not a fair
estimation of us and i think that's what
we are in at the moment it's one of the
things i'm trying to push back against
is to say what they're doing is not fair
uh what they have said about british
history these ideologues in recent years
is not fair it's not fair what they've
said about america um it's it's not the
case that slavery is a unique evil of
america every damn society in world
history did slavery in some form and
many for a lot longer um it's not fair
to pretend that
that some societies have original sins
like
britain america okay what's the original
sin of nigeria tell me that
what's the original sin of uh uganda
tell me that what's the original sin of
of iraq tell me that what's the original
sin of singapore tell me that
don't tell me that only western
societies have original sins and that
we're stuck with them for all time which
is what people like the hukster
dominatrix of so-called anti-racism
robin d'angelo pretends
that we're stuck with this stuff and we
can't escape it oh but the rest of the
world doesn't have it
i've had enough of these people
douglas don't you think that what this
is
what we're really talking about here is
the death of nuance
we don't see that nothing has nuance
anymore everything's binary everything
is you know trump or biden brexit remain
and now with this you know the british
were evil
colonizing nazi racist robber
nobody ever talks and nobody ever takes
the time to analyze the subject to look
at the good the bad and then come to
their own informed decision we just
interested in in reflex reactions well
it's it's it's worse than that isn't it
francis i mean they they actually come
for people who try new ones
somebody who's been a guest on your show
uh nigel bigger
um
experienced this himself i mentioned him
in the war on the west uh
he a couple years ago at oxford
university after the cecil rhodes um
debate about whether or not the statue
of cecil rhodes should be torn from the
edifice of oriole college
um
looked into cecil rhodes in a way that
other people didn't read the
read the entry about him in the
dictionary of national biography and um
and said oh actually people are making
stuff up which they are i've proven the
book that the rhodes must fall campaign
just made up things that cecil rhodes
said they made they
they put the n-word into his mouth in
quotes
that didn't have it you know i mean it's
a sort of weird thing to do to to make
somebody more racist or to seek to make
somebody more racist historically to fit
your own pattern nigel biger and among
others uh pointed this out and was just
subjected to a slurry of abuse
from his peers i mean other historians
and and he said
and tried to at oxford set up a a course
in the ethics of empire
to say we should look into how to
discern if we are going through this
post-colonial post empire phase let's
try to work out
how we think about it now nigel biger
isn't some
uh weird whack job extremist he's
he's the regis professor of ethics at
oxford university
you know
uh he's not suddenly shooting his mouth
off
uh and
he was mauled for this
um his uh people withdrew from his orbit
they withdrew from involvement in the
course uh um other academics not least
uh one particular fool at cambridge
university just defamed him in the most
unbelievable way
and and so that's so the problem is
slightly worse than you say france i
mean it's not just it's not just that
that as it were there's a there's a
reward
for taking an extreme stance and
sticking with it
uh there's there's a cost to trying to
introduce nuance as nigel biger did
there's a cost to that and
i mean one of the one of the points i
would make on this and do in the book is
you know somebody said to me recently no
what's
what's the best thing that can be said
about the british empire
and i said amritsar
and i could see us like
you know uh
worry on the face of of the questioner
tonight the amritsar massacre was a it
was a terrible thing
in 1919 it was a terrible thing
uh british troops opened fire on a crowd
and a crowd of unarmed indians
winston churchill decried it in the
house of commons along with many others
immediately afterwards the reason i said
amritsar is because
in any other empire in history i would
submit we wouldn't know the name of
amritsar
if it was the belgian empire we wouldn't
know the name uh if if it was russian
troops that had
carried out that massacre we wouldn't
know the name of it if it was german
troops
it would be too small an event to
register on the radar
but we remember it because it was
the british empire that did it
so
and then that comes back to a point
actually all well made about gandhi as
it is
sort of impossible to improve on points
in in almost any other
scenario mr gandhi would not have been
heard of
because mr gandhi would have been
disappeared
um he had gone into some prison system
so
so let's have some perspective on this
let's have some understanding of of this
and and i i try to try among other
things to arm people with the facts on
this i think i think the facts basically
got lost
in the last generation uh because people
decided that things like slavery and
empire
were sort of they weren't so much in
vogue to study
and so
only ideological obsessives who hated
western societies decided to focus on
them and effectively the field was left
was left vacant so that things were said
about our societies that were
untrue and and
people basically got away with it
yeah for the reason that you give which
is anyone who attempted to introduce
some measure of facts inter would
immediately be destroyed smeared etc uh
and douglas i know that you're you're
not a conspiratorial person but how
do you see is this a war that the west
is waging on itself or are the people in
our societies who are minded to do this
getting help
oh that's a very interesting question um
uh several things one i think to a great
extent it has happened organically
as i say it's a sort of response
but there is obviously a
a huge interest in the rest of the world
uh or certainly countries that dislike
the western
democracies uh whipping this along um i
have i have a chapter as you know i mean
i do these uh i do in the book each each
chapter is uh the first one is
essentially the war on white people
which i think is an extraordinarily
dangerous
thing that is going on at the moment
where only white people were allowed to
be spoken about in in the most
derogatory racializing terms
um which we would rightly deplore if it
was used against anybody else so the
first chapter is basically the war on
white people then the war on western
history but then the war on western um
uh religion
and ideas including its philosophy and
then the war on uh on western culture
which is you know where we see this
remorseless movement just
take everything in our past the part and
everything we've inherited that's good
but in between like in the madness of
crowds i do these these these interlude
chapters as you know and one of the
interview chapters is you know what
what's the rest of the world doing
whilst we do this
and
and
and an example of something that i give
there which is much of my mind i mean
first of all like
did you i mean you don't but i mean like
does anybody serious
think that china cares about racism
anybody honestly think that because if
so they are
totally deluded
uh
but
uh at the united nations uh a year ago
uh in the opening months of the biden
administration
ambassador linda thomas greenfield the
united states ambassador to the un
gave a speech on one of these sort of
international racism awareness days you
know on these
days it always does a lot of good
um and uh she gave a speech at the u.n
where she talked about how racist
america
is
and she talked about george floyd
and she talked about uh
oh the asians the the the spa incident
where this that guy you know
a year ago it was guy um
maniac shot up a massage parlor
and because
um
a number of the women were
of age and origin uh it was uh put down
as an anti-asian hate crime by some
person turned out that actually um that
didn't seem to be the man's motivation
uh he was just a
maniac he also seemed to have a sex
addiction and seemed to be attacking the
massage parlor because
in fact it was a massage parlor not
because the women were asian i go into
this why because linda thomas windshield
before the facts were out gave that as
an example of ongoing racism in america
so she's on the floor of the united
nations telling the world that america
is racist because of something that was
not a racist incident
oh and at the end of the speech
ambassador thomas greenfield of the
united states remembers to say also
there is racism going on the rest of the
world after all the weaker concentration
camps in china and also uh the treatment
of the rohingya muslims in myanmar and
the next speaker up on the floor of the
united nations is the chinese ambassador
of the united nations who says you have
no right america has no right to talk
about china because it has done this is
what the representatives from china said
it has done something america has done
something unprecedented in the history
of the united nations it has come here
and confessed to its racism and its
guilt
so we will not listen to them
wow
i'm like what an own goal so this is
this is one of the problems is that
is that
bad actors like uh
like the the chinese communist party
certainly
government in moscow and
and and other just hostile governments
are hostile to the west
it seems quite quite understandably they
they they think well they want a gift
this this these people seem to think
that they're guilty of everything that's
wrong in the world and
and so on and we happen to be able to
pretend that we agree with them for
cynical reasons
um and sometimes push that along um but
i think that it is a self-inflicted
wound first and foremost you know we've
allowed we've allowed people to say
these things about ourselves from our
own societies you know the problem is
it's it's our institutions have gone
rotten in countries like britain you
know it's the mayor of london who set up
after the the madness of the
post-george floyd moment
um who set up a a commission for
what's it for
statuary in the public realm or
something like that had some
crazily robespierre-esque title
and um and this this commission
to investigate what needs to come down
in london and what needs to come up
first of all who the hell do you think
you are
to be to have the right to decide that
who the hell could you appoint to such a
committee to decide that you know even
if nigel biger was was the chair of that
committee i think no i don't think i
don't think
any committee has the right to just
decide what should and shouldn't be
allowed from our past and our
inheritance in our capital city in
london to remain on
display but they didn't appoint a any
kind of offender they appointed a bunch
of radicals
to decide what our what our past should
be they employed
people like that not a uh black activist
who um who abused the queen in
westminster abbey and had to be escorted
out
a few years ago and threatened to punch
a black security guard at westminster
abbey that they got him to be one of the
members of this rosterian committee to
decide what our past was you know they
they it's it's it's it's the same thing
institution across institution the
national trust you know
uh what's the national multi-million
member organization where people would
you know decent
you know
mainly middle class people pay money to
be members of an organization where they
can at the weekend go to a nice house
and enjoy a cup of tea
the heads of that organization
um believe in something called the green
unpleasant land this is one of the
documents they they published about
britain the green unpleasant land
uh
that everything to do with britain is
racist
i mean i i of course as ever i have
great fun with some of these people but
i mean
one of my favorite bits of my book if i
could say so myself is the chapter on
racist gardening
um
um
the the the everything is racism
gardening is racist the lawns are racist
um
order is racist um
well to hell with these people they've
taken over institution after institution
in our own country didn't need the
kremlin to appoint these people the
national trust did it to itself the
mayor of london did it to us you know
consecutive politicians did it to us
it's the labour party that commissioned
a report and published it talking about
reparations britain paid reparations
we've paid down our reparations we don't
owe anyone any reparations we don't but
it was the british labour party that
commissioned a report that claimed that
we do we do this to ourselves it's
conservative politicians who can't stand
up for our own country's culture you
know it's it's our own mps who don't
know our past
that didn't need the ccp to teach us
that they just piggyback off the back of
this
horrible horrible masochistic society
that we've been created
hey constantine do you want better
mental health i'm from russia we don't
have mental health so how do you deal
with mental health you drink vodka then
go out and wrestle bear if you live you
feel better if you die you're not real
men what about the bears feelings it's
russian bear it has no feelings people
don't always realize that physical
symptoms like headaches teeth grinding
and even digestive issues can be
indicators of stress and let's not
forget about doom scrolling not sleeping
enough sleeping too much under eating
and overeating sleeping too much under
eating this is western disease therapy
has really helped me in my life to
concentrate and focus it's really
important to have someone impartial who
you can talk to about the tricky issues
that you're struggling to deal with
therapy has played a really important
role in helping me to deal with my adhd
and become better in all areas of my
life why is he telling them how weak he
is drink vodka feel better better help
is customized online therapy that offers
video phone and even live chat sessions
with your therapist so you don't have to
see anyone on camera if you don't want
to trigonometry funds get 10 off their
first month at betterhelp.com forward
slash trigger especially if they're not
real men that's b e t t e r h e l p dot
com slash trigger
douglas
let's be fair isn't this just preying on
white guilt this is all it is i remember
talking to a friend of mine a comedian
uh asian guy and i said to him what why
do you think this is all happening ah
it's just monetizing white guilt
yes i think that's i think that's great
that's greatly true so let me say
something that needs to be said i don't
feel any white guilt
i don't feel any guilt
hereditary guilt i feel guilt for things
i've done in my own life that have been
wrong i feel guilt sometimes to my
actions towards other people which are
not as generous as they could have been
i feel
guilty about my own life i feel no
hereditary guilt and nobody else should
either
nobody else should either
you are not guilty because you are born
white any more than you are guilty
because you are born black it is a
totally neutral thing
it is the place that you start from
nothing is built into it
so
what has happened is that too few people
have been willing in recent years to say
what i just said it's a straightforward
thing
no there is no such thing as white guilt
we will not have you pretending that
there is we will not have you pretending
that there are what i mean what's the
latest pathologizing terms we've had uh
we've had white tears we've had white
women's tears we've had missing white
woman syndrome uh given to us by msnbc
when a a woman was was killed by her
boyfriend both of them white and and
this
unbelievable racist huxster in america
um said this is missing white woman
syndrome that people no no people
actually just just
you know are kind of against people
being murdered by their boyfriends they
don't like it
um there's no racialization of it
uh
but we have all this what's a white rage
white rage remember that one
and this isn't one of the things i keep
trying to bring across i hope i do is
that this isn't some fringe movement
this isn't just ibrahim x kendi not you
know talking in some silo
this is the chairman of the joint chiefs
of staff mark milley
saying to senate and congress
that he wants to look into white rage
there's no such thing as white rage
there's no such thing just that there's
no such thing as white tears or white
guilt or anything else no such thing
and if you do think there's such a thing
then play it the other way around say
you're interested in black rage
say you're interested in black tears and
that you want to taunt people when
they're black and they cry how dare how
dare people talk like this they would
never do it about anybody else and it's
high time they stop doing it about white
people it's absolutely reprehensible and
disgusting and you're quite right
francis it's people
taking advantage of basically
this
scared and cowed white people who are
fearful that these things actually exist
that they should feel some guilt or
historical
you know
responsibility and and then the way the
race hucksters come along the robin
d'angelos the abrahamics candies and so
on and my god are they coining it
so i i'm one of my self-appointed roles
is to put an end to that racket
and douglas the fact that this racket is
has been effective uh or as effective as
it has been
is that a product of our success are we
that comfortable are we that rich are we
do we have that much spare time now
that we can engage in this naval gazing
because we're no longer scrapping to
survive to to put food on the table is
that where it's coming from yeah well i
i would have thought that um
and i would have hoped it in a way
and i think that actually when we spoke
at one point during the pandemic near
the beginning of the pandemic i think we
might even have said that maybe the
pandemic was going to do away with the
sort of identity politics era you know
i have a natural predisposition to
hoping that anything something anything
does away with the woke [ __ ] at some
point i i've got a natural
predisposition because i i just don't
want to talk about it a moment longer
than i have to i don't want my i don't
want my brain cells to be clogged up
with this detritus
um
and
and so of course i wish it was the case
um i just see that you know the same
games being played i suppose my
my
my short my my
my prediction such as it is obviously
stupid to make predictions at any time
particularly my prediction in a way of
that at the moment is this i think that
i think the people who do that are going
to double down
but the rest of society is going to have
less tolerance for it
i i and i think that's because and
lionel shriver said this recently as
well that
you know the woke stuff was always a
a rich
time and a rich people's obsession i
mean it was a it
happened because of a society that
didn't have enough problems
you know it we didn't have enough of the
things that were being complained about
you know it's only if you've got
a society that doesn't tolerate
aggression
that you can decide to go to the lair
below that and decide to police
microaggressions
like
no society in history before ours would
have given a damn about so-called
micro-aggressions
uh so it's it's a product of wealth
boredom
uh bad education illiteracy and much
more uh but but it's it's
i'm i'm pretty confident that as
sadly that as we're all up for we
already are suffering economically many
many people
have lost their jobs uh and don't see
how they're going to be able to
keep their finances together i just
expect that those people are going to
care or even less than they already did
if sam smith claims that somebody
misgendered him according to what he
claims to be this fortnight
and
uh and i think that's fine i think
that'd be a healthy thing i i think i
think we have as i say we've all had our
minds clogged up by a lot too much
nonsense
and
but as i say i mean you know both of
these things can happen simultaneously
people doubling down and the wider
population's saying no we've we've had
enough of that we've we've got real
problems now so you don't have time for
your imaginary ones
um
you know within those seconds you've got
uh the racialization of the pandemic you
know you have
uh what's her name
sort of one of the british race huxters
who
you know only achievement has been to
write a memoir about growing up in the
wild hoods of wimbledon
but uh and then to describe her
appalling impression of when he plays at
oxford university um
after her she used to be an it girl
before she became
an aggrieved uh um campaigner for social
justice
uh so that that's what can happen in our
era by the way i mean the the canny
people of all types uh um spot where
it's going and they adjust their stories
appropriately
um
and and they they present
the most successful societies as being
the least successful
they present
the most racially diverse and harmonious
societies as the least
racially harmonious and diverse and i'm
afraid at this point it's sometimes
quite hard to disentangle
the reality and i i it's one of the
things i tried to do in the book but
by the way before i do say what i'm
about to say let me also add
i think that you and i uh
you two and i if we're talking at the
beginning of the ukraine war
after russia's invasion of ukraine might
have said oh maybe this
crap is gonna stop in the west
again sorry for lawn hope
uh nothing seems to wake us up to the
fact that we're doing these mad things
but we are
misrepresenting ourselves to ourselves
and it's provable let me give you a
quick example
there was a poll in 2020 which asked
americans um
how many
unarmed black americans they think are
shot every year by the american police
and
among people who described themselves as
liberal a very significant number
thought that the figure was somewhere
between one thousand and ten thousand
among people who described themselves as
very liberal
a significant portion i think about 40
said that the number was over 10 000.
that is that more than 10 000 unarmed
black men are killed every year by the
american police do you know what the
figure was that year 10 10
10.
so they're off by several orders of
magnitude
um now and by the way
10 is is is
um
less than the number of american police
officers killed by armed black men in
the same period so put that aside for a
second america has has
many many problems with my like every
country but
but
it's provable that the american public
have a totally distorted view of their
own country now because the press and
the media and race huxters and others
have given them a distorted view so it
becomes quite hard for people to work
out what is real and what is not you
know i think most of us because we were
locked in our isolation during the
post-george floyd period had a moment of
thinking on seeing the news about his
his death
thinking
crikey can you do that in america
is it the case that policemen can just
kill black people
with impunity and the answer is of
course of course not of course not
um
but there was a moment because everyone
had lost their social antenna and much
more where i think a lot of people
thought maybe that is the case
there's this there's this song that
actually happened john peterson and i
the other week with a a
show in new york where there was a um by
david burns and there was a song
during a show where he said i've asked
to borrow this song
because uh um
which is the say her name song say their
name
totally banal
it's not really a song it's just a chant
and uh david burns scottish born pop
star said uh
uh you know i asked if i could sing this
despite the fact that i'm a white male
and you know do i have the right and all
this sort of [ __ ] and i
i said to jordan arthur's god it just
feels like you can never escape doesn't
it you can't go the matinee at the
theater without having this crap forced
down our throats it's just so
demoralizing anyhow but the point is
that that song is a total croc we can
all say the names of every single person
who was shot by the american police in
recent years in in the last decade
in
debatable circumstances everybody knows
the name of brianna taylor
you know everyone knows the name of
freddie gray
it's not like these are hidden names we
pretend these are hidden cases
of of secret oppression by the american
state horrible things were done in in
the in the american past like every
country but i mean it is not the case
that today
this is permissible and goes on yet the
american people have been told it has i
give the examples in the book of just i
mean ludicrous examples american
campuses that keep having these weird
morals
stampedes
um in in the last decade i have great
fun with it but in the last decade
they've been
oh i mean american campuses where one
was in put into lockdown because there
was a claimed sighting of a member of
the kkk walking around campus with a
whip
[Music]
guys what do you think is the likelihood
that solitary members of the kkk wander
around liberal arts colleges in america
holding whips what do you think the
chances are
zero nada
okay the campus goes into lockdown uh it
turns out that the alleged member of the
kkk is a dominican monk who is walking
across campus carrying a rosary
you have you have examples of of
campuses going into meltdown because
there have been alleged sightings of a
noose
as if there's a lynching about to happen
okay and it turns out it's
the plastic
wrap of a refuse sack
that was lying on the floor on another
occasion a campus goes into meltdown in
america because a girl says that a noose
has been hung outside the dorm room
it and the kkk therefore were clearly
present that day and it turns out that
somebody put a spare shoelace on a hook
so this is a society in america in
particular that is is deranged and has a
deranged and wrong-headed view of itself
it's why when i was in
america before the 2020 election in like
seattle the whole foods had a great big
sign bigger than the sign that but the
whole thing was boarded up of course but
there was there was a sign that said
whole foods just so you knew which
boarded up hellhole shop you were going
into but a much bigger sign said racists
are not welcome here
well who the hell thought they were
who the hell thought that the kkk gather
in the fruit and nut aisle of the whole
foods in seattle
uber
hide the whole side of a building
to say that racists if you're a racist
don't have don't download our app
we don't want you
where's the evidence of so much racism
that uber has to take out an entire side
of a building to say this
there is americans have been force-fed a
false interpretation of their present
and to the
enormous detriment of the rest of us in
the west we've all been made to imbibe a
version of it ourselves as well
and it is partly a product of our
well-to-do-ness
are our boredom our lack of causes
our desire to be part of a great cause
our
loss of meaning uh or
and and much more and are just our
comfort
um
of course it has much to do with that
we wouldn't be doing this if as you say
uh
that we had to you know worry about
putting food on the table
it's it's and my worry is that what
we're actually doing is you know
basically we're killing the goose that
laid the golden egg you know
but at the end of all of this at the end
of
the system's
most likely to set up
harmonious
societies where people can get on
and
get on not just with each other but get
on in their lives we decide these are
the just the most oppressive societies
the most original sin written societies
and
just best to do away with it
douglas
we're talking about
racism and the perception of race but it
mirrors exactly what happened with
covert my girlfriend's from new york
when she went back to new york to see
the organization that she worked in the
people she knew the people she went to
college with
they're absolutely terrified about kovid
they refused to hug her in central park
then some of them were still and well
this was a couple of months ago and some
of them were wearing two masks and these
were intelligent people who went to ivy
league colleges so it's not just about
racism it's also something to me far
deeper where we
many ways we live a life that's so safe
that we can't properly assess risk
without completely losing our minds oh
that's that's certainly true that's
certainly true um
i personally resign myself to the fact
that there will be a portion of the
public who will triple mask for the rest
of time well
farewell to them
farewell to them
you know
shame not to see their faces but there
we go we lost them uh
i i
there are people for whom particularly
america that's just an identity issue
and
largely created by the absurd um
way in which everything in american
politics is just totally binary
if donald trump had been pro-masked
uh republicans would have been
pro-mosque and democrats would be
flaunting their noses and their chins in
public
they would be they would be congregating
in in public places inside without masks
it's only because the republican donald
trump went one way that they went so far
the other and that's just that's how
american politics works now and you've
just got to try to step away from being
too deranged by it yourself well douglas
let me interrupt you there because this
is something i wanted to ask you very
much about which is the derangement that
seems to be happening and of course your
last book was called the madness of
crowds yeah and you talked largely about
the madness of crowds that is coming
from the very people we've been talking
about today but in in recent times i
think both you and i and some other
people have also noticed that there's a
every action has an equal and opposite
reaction and there is an equal and
opposite derangement that seems to me
emerging on the other side of the
political spectrum talk to us about that
well this is very interesting i'm so
glad you bring this up um yes you're
completely right
um
some years ago jordan and i had a
conversation about where the left goes
wrong and we had it on the
uh
presumption that we recognized both of
us and perhaps wider people recognize
where the right goes wrong and therefore
it was more fruitful to have a
discussion about where the left goes
wrong because people haven't really
worked that out
and
still haven't
today i mean i'd say
we also need to have that discussion
about where the right goes wrong
because there are clearly elements of
the american right and
and and european right and others who
are going wrong
and there's somebody who's more
identified with that side than the
ideological left you know that is that
is a concern to me and is
is um is terrain that worries me i'm i'm
not interested in
not critiquing people who are you know
vaguely allied with me or on my own side
you know i and i think that
i think
well if i just say i want your view on
this i mean
i think basically what's happened the
last few years we've had we've had to
have succession of things has
essentially isolated all of us from each
other i mean um
the covert debate was highly
highly divisive because it was something
most of us have not thought about and
suddenly everybody had extremely strong
views about very few people thought
about pandemics suddenly you had to have
very strong views um
and that was totally unconnected with
all the existing
well aside from the politicization of it
in america it was largely unconnected i
should say with most pre-existing
ideological divides so the kobe thing
came down to it it split people
even among each other and families even
people among people pretty much agreed
then you had things like the masking
thing that that did more of it then you
had things like the
look at the ivormectin debate i mean
there are people who've fallen out with
each other over whether or not ivamekton
is a the miracle cure for covid or be
not
um with no permitted terrain in the
middle for i don't know we don't seem to
know quite enough maybe that's something
but it's not the wonder drug that you
you know
that's divided people
then you come acro then russia i don't
know fast forward to a whole succession
of other
crazy events russia invades ukraine and
then that suddenly divides people as
well you you
my point is that on the sort of family
tree of events that have occurred in
recent years very few of us
have traveled exactly the same path
and ended up in exactly the same place
you know they'll
and and
and so i think we've probably all had
the experience of feeling like we've
lost
friends
to
some corner of this
and finding it hard to bring them back
and and in a way that i don't want to
say bring them back because that sounds
that sounds like there's a correct
position and just set of obviously
incorrect ones i don't want to suggest
that i i
uh maybe i could put it better i think
keeping them in the fold of the
reasonable discussion something like
that
the one thing i would say douglas that
you you mentioned you know having
our input on it
that maybe is worth adding to the mix of
the things that you've talked about
is
the deep deep alienation many many
people feel with the mainstream
media yeah absolutely and the product of
that is i think when you talk about
russia and ukraine and you've written
recently about
a fringe of the right in america seeming
to to to like putin and be obsessed with
him and think he's doing the right thing
mm-hmm i think
yeah
well let's talk about that in a sec
because i think
for me where part of that comes from
is there are a lot of people who
who now believe that the truth is the
opposite of whatever the mainstream
media says absolutely
absolutely
i think that's where it's coming from to
a logic story absolutely um you can see
it in the people who are like
bored with with president zielenski
being presented as a hero
like i'm bored of him being presented as
a hero therefore i'll find out other
stuff about him decide he's a nazi
yes you're right to a great extent it is
what
and
again people are on to something about
the the the suspicion
of the narrative they're given you know
i agree with that i mean i'm i'm pretty
fed up with the way in which you know
i mean obviously for most of us for many
people
the the the moment of transition that
was sharpest and most obvious was the
movement between stay at home isolate
and then get onto the streets and
protest about racism
okay
the movement i had a lot of readers who
said this to me that the that was one
where the whiplash was
was
clear enough that people noticed it
definitely that
that that suddenly the the pandemic was
replaced by another pandemic which was
racism and that that and the answers to
that were totally the opposite of the
answers to the other fandom so i think a
lot of people have that um uh so so we
have right that we have good reasons to
be rightly suspicious of media
narratives and of political narratives
however
that does not mean that as you say that
the opposite of everything is
true
um
and
uh
i think there is on the russia thing
there are a set of things but the most
interesting to me
is
well two things i made very quickly one
is let's talk again historical ignorance
we are dealing very significantly with
people who know we've discussed this
before no nothing about uh communism no
nothing about the communist era no
nothing about the cold war no nothing
about russia in the 20th century
know nothing about
about the kremlin
and are discovering have been
discovering it for the first time
i mean imagine imagine somebody who has
grown up
into you know born in 2002 say a
complete sentient adult they're now
they're now 20 years of age they were
born after 9 11
they were born
more than a decade after the end of the
cold war the breakup of the soviet union
um and suddenly they're told about
russia and ukraine and what do they know
they just learn fast they learn
something fast what's the best way to do
that just grab a grab an opinion off the
shelf
um
and you can do it on any subject but
this is this is one of them
so that's one thing is
we are we are very often talking in in
this space with people who
who genuinely seem to find it surprising
that for instance there is such a thing
as russian disinformation
well but but again
you can't entirely blame them because on
the one hand they never knew anything
about russia yeah they never knew
anything about the kremlin or its
tactics and on the other hand they've
been
force-fed lies about kremlin
disinformation in recent years and
everybody who voted brexit was told that
they'd done it because the kremlin told
them to do it and everyone who voted
trump was told that it was a kremlin
that made him do it so to hell with your
kremlin stories i'm going to watch
russia today get the real story so
that's one thing
hey francis do you like books i tried
one once wasn't for me mike not enough
pictures of fit brand birds never
working with you again but if you like
fantasy check out the ripples in reality
series by j.s pal they're absolutely
brilliant and they have a five gold star
rating on amazon i've heard of them
they're beautifully written and
completely original if you want a book
that allows you to delve into different
worlds and helps you escape the insanity
of real life then ripples in reality is
for you
see i know the word delve so i do read
books amazing just imagine books written
in the style of game of thrones lord of
the rings forgotten realms with an added
pinch of stargate it's catnip for people
like me virgins
she started a publishing company named
poppy field publishing and her novels
are a massive hit with fans who want to
read books that are a great read and are
not woke book one is shadow step
and book two gather shadows
she's currently writing book number
three i can't wait i don't read books
because i can talk to girls your mom
doesn't count mate and by the way js
powell is a big supporter of
trigonometry she is a moderator on our
channel and we really appreciate all her
help you can find her books online at
amazonlulu.com and other bookseller
websites if you enjoy the books please
leave a review the links are in the
description
[Music]
the second thing which uh which is in a
way is
is even more interesting to me is
let's start to admit something which
nobody has yet which is that the right
has been going wrong recently because
it's it's it's absorbed a form of the
criticism of its own society that was
previously the preserve of the
ideological left
so
since the war in ukraine started there
are people on the right
saying things like
who are we
to stop uh vladimir putin look at the
millions of people we killed in iraq
now that apart from being untrue about
the millions of people killed the
people killed in iraq like in
afghanistan were primarily killed by
islamists and various other militia
is not to over ride any of the mistakes
made but
my point is that is a that is a claim
and a figure that used to only come from
the chomskyite left
you never heard that from patriotic
americans
of the right
they didn't do that there was a sort of
buchananite fringe of the right who
played with some of that stuff an
isolationist fringe of the right but you
didn't hear those left-wing stories of
who are we because we did this bad thing
in in the vietnam or something and
therefore we don't have the right to do
this now or to criticize people now that
used to be the left that did that now
segment of the right is doing it let me
give you another example
um
my
close enemy uh julian assange uh
used to be
uh a hero only to parts of the left
he's become a hero to parts to the right
edward snowden the sniveling little grot
bag used to be a
hero only to the american left and he's
become a hero to the american right
like
part of the right has gone into the same
place that part of the left used to be
in and i desperately want them to come
back in
from it
you know edward snowden
decided to mass steal american national
security secrets and expose the
intelligence gathering secrets of
america and her allies including britain
sort sanctuary it seems first of all in
china and ended up plumping to have
sanctuary in
putin's russia
does anyone think that there's something
completely kosher about that
okay you may you may deplore some of the
things that were discovered in the
snowden files but
you have to be an idiot to think that
edward snowden is is some kind of whiter
than white hero in this
but a part of the right now does just
like a part of the left used to
and i mean i've remained
filled with hatred of both of these
people
consistently for the last decade because
i think if you did have concerns for
instance about
the way in which
you're
if you worked for the intelligence
community and you had concerns about how
it's operating there are many better
ways to address that i should have
thought that handing over all of those
secrets to vladimir putin or the chinese
communist party um
so
yeah i i i'm sort of amazed to watch a
part of the right to do this
um it's ended up and it's so unpatriotic
i i
and then they go into other conspiracy
theories i mean there are people on the
right in america who now sort of say
things like you know i'm starting to
doubt whether we actually landed on the
moon
but you're even taking away
your extraordinary accomplishments
like you can you can answer this
constantly i mean
you know russia managed to land on the
moon um
is there anyone in russia who would
consider themselves as ordinarily
patriotic who would
doubt that they did
or would think the whole thing was made
up
no i don't know no i mean i mean can you
imagine anyone doing that douglas let me
posit a theory for you and see what you
think about this my working theory on
why there are elements of the right
doing this
is that because of the media lies and
because of the political lies we have
had for a period of time and because of
the intensity of those lies and the
consistency of those lies there is a
portion of so the the far left though
always hated the west they hate the west
in general and they support the west
enemies and that's par for the course
and we expect that but on the right what
i think is happening is
there are sections of the right that are
so disillusioned with what has been
happening as frankly you and i and
francis all are really
but their response to that is to hate
the western elites
as much as the far left hate the west
and so they now feel like
some kind of a affinity with people who
are attacking what they think are the
western elites they think of vladimir
putin this christian christian
yeah that's one of the best totally
uncynically adopted the
christian faith yeah yeah the kgb
colonel head of the kgb massive
christian is all about turning now that
she can forget yes
um
they think that he is
a a beacon of
uh of some kind of pushback against this
uh this anti-christian anti uh you know
he's pushing back against the trans
which they they think vladimir putin
really cares about trans douglas that's
it
i think that what do you think of what
do you make of that idea yeah i think
that's true i think there's a segment of
the right that mistakenly thinks of
right over the criminal influence as
being a bulwark against
uh the craziness of our own side and
this is one of the reasons why this
needs to be addressed yeah it's where
the whole damn thing needs to be
addressed why we need to get our past in
correct order for instance or some in
some correct approximation it's why we
need to
in the present not derange ourselves
with absolutely ludicrous stories i mean
um
you know obviously i wrote about that
stuff in the manners of crowds but um
you know i just you know wrote about
recently this story of uh
it's just too much fun not to mention
but one of the
the the the the woman who used the
wheelie bin as a sex toy in public
exposing her penis
and his girlfriend god's sake first of
all
how do you use a wheelie bill as a sex
toilet and that's a very strange or any
form of thin
uh anyhow but then that's not what's
wrong with the the headliner that i mean
that's comparatively minor in the
headline of anything like her penis
what
now
of course there was a type of person and
i know some uh i mean like my friend
sarah bamari would be one who who just
who says i confess i've had enough of it
i've
i've had enough of this liberal madness
i've had enough of her penis
i've had enough of um
of all this stuff
um
western liberalism
the problem
it's the same thing with i mean i think
actually again surab um
felt bad over the silencing of the new
york post by twitter and facebook
that was a total scandal an unbelievable
scandal i'm a columnist in york post
i love the paper i think it's an
absolute scandal what happened where the
post got the hunter biden files tried to
run them before the election with really
important information which now the rest
of the media has admitted uh was true
and wasn't russian disinformation
despite the fact again that dozens of
members of the senior former members of
the intelligence community claimed that
it was russian disinformation um but you
know there's
sora one of his things was yeah you know
basically i'm out you know twitter can
censor america's oldest newspaper and
silence it
and stop a story getting out there
because they want their guy joe biden in
office like the whole thing's corrupt
i'm out
you know i understand it i i do because
we probably all have moments where we
think that but but i in my view the
alternatives are all
at least as bad and almost certainly
much much worse
much much worse
if you mind um internet uh um domination
by a few
um tech overlords in silicon valley
um then
your answer is not does not lie in
russia
it doesn't lie in
eastern europe it it's it's
this is this is this is to this you know
there are examples of places you can
learn from there are small examples you
can take but
but i i that's what i think is happening
is is people have have people got so
sick of the stuff i'm describing
that they're that they're
they're basically calling time they want
out
and um i wish they wouldn't because i
think we need them
douglas don't you think part of it as
well is that we're all being encouraged
to see ourselves as victims
and once you see yourself as being a
victim whether you're right and you're
left you start to feel put upon and once
you start to feel put upon and things
are happening to you then you become
innately suspicious and you start seeing
patterns where they don't exist
i agree i agree well our era obviously
prioritizes victimhood over heroism i
don't go along with this it's one of the
many things i say people you don't have
to go along with that you don't have to
at all i don't
um i don't like whiners
i don't like people who pretend to be
victims particularly i i don't like
people who who present themselves as
victims even when they are victims
um
i think broadly speaking the world is
has got enough reasons to be unhappy
without you adding to the general flow
of misery
um uh so i certainly don't have any time
for would-be victims or aspiring victims
or wannabe victims
um
and i have no
truck with those people who use it as a
way to try to browbeat me
or you or anyone else any of us
um speaking out i come from x
communities so what what's your point
you know
i want to tell you that my ancestors
okay so what what's your point
um you don't
we live in an era where you era where
you where you get to grab the mic if you
can present yourself as a victim
not interested
sorry you can't make me interested in
you because of that
uh
if if you actually have a story of um
actual oppression that is relevant to
the discussion we're having then sure
let's discuss that
but um
uh all of this uh sort of
i've been diagnosed bipolar
you have to listen to me diagnose oh
oh um i've been
actually prescribed
to diagnose ptsd
now we've got to listen to you i guess
no no
people have problems in their lives we
all do
uh but look at the look at the people
who use that stuff
again a close enemy owen jones when he
was recently when he was recently hauled
over the coals for his proven
misogynistic bullying of female
colleagues of the guardian when this was
exposed in private eye uh owen jones and
his um his cohorts decided to present it
as homophobia
i might i don't think privatized the
greatest magazine i don't think it's
been particularly funny in about 20
years but um
i don't think it's the home of
homophobia
and whenever they've
gone for me as they have occasionally uh
i don't say oh it's homophobia
it's a certain type of person does
a certain type of person wants to win
and uses alleged victimhood status as
the means to win to hell with these
people not interested don't have the
time
but douglas it's a right doing it as
well because the right side you know
with the woke are trying to destroy us
they're trying to you know they're
trying to ruin our reputations and look
you know there is
that does that argument does have
certain value but then they're
portraying themselves as victims as well
so you before you used to be just the
left doing it now the right are playing
the same game
and that's even more worrying yes i
think so i mean i think people if it
would be it would be as worrying um
i i think that's true to some extent and
again it depends on on the extent which
it's the case i mean
i i do think that people have a right to
feel aggrieved
if they are told that there is nothing
good about themselves you'll notice that
what i said just now about victimhood i
didn't say as a result the people
are of zero value
i said i'm not interested in people
using victimhood alleged or otherwise as
a way to grab the microphone and
browbeat other people i didn't say
therefore they have no right to speak
that i don't think that's the legitimate
qualification to speak
if you said
by dint of the thing you are claiming
you have zero right to be heard then
that person would have a
right to be uh aggrieved
likewise
i believe that people of the right and
mainstream are right to feel aggrieved
when people come at them and say you
have nothing to be proud of but worse
than that look
go back again to what what i i quote in
the book the opening chapter
of what robin d'angelo and libra makes
candy and coast say now about white
people they say and robin deangelo says
she says
she's of course white herself um robin
d'angelo says
there is no good form of whiteness
okay no good form of whiteness and it
cannot be escaped
so you're locked
you're locked in
of course again she would not say that
any other people she would not say
there's no good form of being indian and
you can't escape or anything like that
she wouldn't say there's no good form of
being black plus you can't ever escape
this is what they say about white people
uh
the uh answer that ibrahim kendi gives
is yes there has been oppression in the
past and the answer to oppression in the
past is oppression basically in the
present
okay so people are right to feel
aggrieved about that they are right to
be to be agreed when they're told shut
up whitey
just as they would have a right to feel
aggrieved if people said shut up you
black
whatever
okay like that would be
a horrible thing to do
so
so
i think that there is a unique
in the current year again it was
different in the past in the current era
there is a unique permissible
mistreatment of certain people
and that's what i think has to stop
and must be stopped
in order among other things not to
create some kind of wild backlash if
it's there
quite well douglas one of the things
that we love about having you on the
show as regulars we do is you're one of
the people who's attempting to char
what i think is a healthy path through
all of this and uh all of us will fall
off the wagon every now and again in
different directions you will we will
but in having these conversations i
think we're trying to do something
productive so thank you very much for
coming back on the book is the war on
the west which everyone of course should
read we're going to do a couple of
questions for our local supporters from
our local supporters but you know that
before we let you go in the main
interview itself we always have the same
final question
uh which is what is the one thing we're
not talking about but we really should
be
oh god i forgot that you asked that
question yes well now you're gonna have
to now you're gonna have to come up with
something god i don't think there's
anything we're not talking about at the
moment it feels like we're talking about
absolutely everything i mean it's
certainly i am um uh
god we're being
uh every as every year feels like a long
year and every day feels like a long day
at the moment
anything we're not talking about that we
should be
i'm gonna have to think about that maybe
we're talking too much douglas maybe
that'll be the title of the episode stop
talking douglas
it's possible you know it's possible
that's not the title of the episode the
title episode is i've had enough of her
penis
i don't want her penis forced down my
throat every morning
that'll get it clicks guys my god you
know how to work this algorithm um no i
actually i actually think that might be
true i think we might have just got to
something i i don't i don't want i don't
want any more people coming at me with
their views on
their newly discovered views on
i don't i don't want the people who
who've just like raced from being
experts in epidemiology
to
experts in afghan
withdrawal tactics to
experts in ukrainian
[Music]
politics and
experts in i have a mechatin and i i
i don't really want to hear too much
more from the people who know all of
these things
and don't want to listen
and just are on
our own play but not listen
yeah
douglas it's been an absolute pleasure
when is the book released
28th of april in the uk
almost immediately after this interview
goes out uh douglas will make sure to
put the link in the description so
people check it out gonna say you can
you can if you can find a bookshop
anymore you can go in and get it there
um you can of course order it from
amazon and all competitors sites
but i really i really hope people um
benefit from this because um
it's uh
for me writing the war in the west has
been one of the most exciting things
i've done i i
can't wait people to read it because
it's just
if i say say myself jammed full with the
things that i think people should know
about what's going on and uh the ways to
uh answer them
douglas it's been an absolute pleasure
if people want to find you online
where's the best way to do that oh you
can find me on twitter for the time
being uh douglas k murray i don't know
how long that'll last
um uh and oh i'm on instagram and
various other places and you can always
find me at
the spectator and various other than the
many venues i i i'm writing at um
in my
highly
prolific um not say promiscuous way
douglas has been a pleasure to have you
back on thank you for being on the show
thank you all for watching and listening
we're about to ask douglas an exclusive
couple of questions from you for you for
our locals but in the meantime enjoy the
rest of your day thank you for watching
and we'll see you very soon with another
brilliant episode like this one or raw
show all of them go out at 7pm uk time
and for those of you who like your
trigonometry on the go it's also
available as a podcast take care and see
you soon guys
the miserable state and fate of the
french elections what does douglas think